this morning u.s intelligence agencies
are sifting through highly sensitive
information
that was gathered in the daring u.s raid
on the isis leaders compound
in northwestern syria president trump
says the terror group's leader that's
abu bakr al-baghdadi killed himself
during that weekend attack
now this is a big victory for president
trump who is accused of giving a
lifeline to isis
when he pulled american troops out of
northern syria the u.s located baghdadi
using information provided by prisoners
including one of his in-laws who met
with the isis leader on a regular basis
chief washington correspondent major
garrett is at the white house with more
on this story major so what else do we
know this morning
about that raid well good morning gail
we know that the army's elite delta
force took the lead about 70 american
commandos participated in this raid it
took about
four and a half hours no u.s military
personnel were killed two were injured
and there were injuries suffered by a
military dog
meanwhile five of baghdadi's terrorist
associates
were killed in the raid on the compound
he didn't die a hero he died a coward
crying
whimpering screaming and president trump
described the final moments of isis
leader abu bakar al-baghdadi as a
contrast in terrorist bravado
and american resolve amateur video
allegedly shows the raid
the thug who tried so hard to intimidate
others
spent his last moments in utter fear
in total panic and dread terrified of
the
american forces bearing down on him mr
trump said fresh intelligence on
baghdadi's likely location and where he
might move set the mission in motion
three days ago
u.s forces took off from a military base
in erbil iraq flying eight helicopters
low
and fast for the roughly one hour and
ten minute trip to the location
once there forces blasted a hole through
the side of the compound catching those
inside by surprise
baghdadi fled to an underground tunnel
he ignited his vest
killing himself and the three children
his body was mutilated by the blast
a test of baghdadi's scattered remains
mr trump said confirmed the identity
the president credited cooperation from
russia turkey iraq and
syria russia treated us great they
opened up
we had to fly over certain russia areas
the syrian courage to have seen the u.s
withdraw from the country as a betrayal
also played a role
they gave us some information that
turned out to be helpful
while some republican lawmakers were
notified sunday morning about the raid
other congressional leaders including
senate minority leader chuck schumer
found out when the rest of the world did
it's great
that we've gotten al baghdadi and killed
him
he's a dangerous man an evil man the
fight against isis has to continue
the raid was code named after kayla
mueller an american aid worker and one
of baghdadi's victims on sunday tony
president trump called
the families of americans killed at the
hands of isis
major garrett forest major thank you